pulled from the rubble following yet
another day of strikes carried out by
the Russian military Ukrainian
authorities say cities across the
country were
targeted in zapa a residential building
was damaged forcing its residents out
into the freezing
cold I saw that there was going to be an
air rate in bombing so we quickly
quickly run to the bomb shelter later we
got a phone call and found out what
happened to the building but we were in
shelter at 7:00 a.m. if we were at home
nothing good would come out of it rescue
workers delivered Aid and told residents
they would cover the blown out windows
in keev residents rushed to shelters but
there were no reports of any missiles
hitting Targets in the capital this has
become a regular occurrence when air
raid sirens are sounded last month keev
was hit killing more people across the
capital in crvy one woman was killed and
children were among the wounded
authorities there say a shopping center
and resident itial buildings were hit
Ukraine says 59 cruise and ballistic
missiles as well as drones were fired by
Russian forces it claims 26 were
intercepted more than half managed to
get through Ukraine has not said whether
any of its military SES were hit or if
it suffered any military losses since
December 29th there's been an increase
of aerial attacks carried out by both
sides and there's no sign that there
will be let up in strikes anytime soon
Assad bag Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer